good afternoon councilors member of the
staff members of the public and those of
us joining on Zoom this is a meeting of
the icc's community wellbeing committee
there are no apologies so we'll get
straight into our first item which is
the public forum and I'll ask the
representatives from South alive to come
and take a seat
introduce yourselves and we look forward
to hearing about
um what you've been doing
Courtney thank you for giving up your
time and joining us this afternoon
thanks so much for the
Barrel Wilcox I'm chair of the South
alive trust and I'm Courtney Ellison on
the community community development
manager
so we're here with a sort of a two-fold
um presentation firstly for those that
are relatively new to the council and
may not know a lot about South light and
what we do we'd love to let you know but
also for those that are well familiar
just providing you with an update on the
work we've been achieving and in
particular our future Focus planning
that we're doing we've just recently
celebrated 11 years as an organization
connecting and enabling our South
invercargill community
the principles of how we operate is
based on the community-led development
approach and I know the council is quite
strong on that Community Development and
the principles are to grow from shared
local Visions to build from our
strengths to work with diverse people
and sectors to grow collaborative local
leadership and to learn by doing and I
guess learn by doing is what we're doing
all the time
so our South alive pod in the pantry is
basically our community Hub and we have
our community rooms there which are used
regularly by many diverse local groups
and businesses we provide extremely low
rates to allow the community to meet
regularly we offer free computer use
with the internet one thing we've found
with the South invercargill Community is
that it access is limited and so it's
really valued for people to be able to
go and receive support and of course our
outdoor areas with the gardens the play
the sports gear and the equipment we
have recently two table tennis tables
have just been installed to a thrilled
about and in that Community Hub once
again we're striving to bring people
together to reduce isolation to share
interests in particular the pantry Cafe
there's a real it's changed a lot over
time to having a real value as a meeting
space and of course the food helps as
well
much of the work that we do extend right
across the wider 9812 community and I
can't stress enough the importance and
appreciation of our volunteers which
contributes to our success their time
actually equates to thousands of hours a
year and we try hard to record what that
means in terms of a dollar value there
are different action groups at work
people that are happy to assist whether
that be through micro volunteering tasks
through to Major projects and I just
want to acknowledge our volunteers we
value their work their time and
commitment and really appreciate their
skills and experience one example is our
volunteers that are working as hosts at
their Community Hub greeting people
answering questions and they then become
have a sort of sense of ownership as
caretakers of our space thank you
thank you
um as barrels said we're led by what the
community is identifying as important to
them and that really drives what we what
we do so a lot of my role is engaging
with the community and we do that
throughout the year but one of the
formal ways that we engage is through
our annual survey that we do
um some of you may have heard in the
past just talk about the change in
levels of Pride that we've seen and that
continues to grow so when we started 11
years ago
um 35 of people who we surveyed got a
sense of pride in South invercargill I
think last time we came and spoke to you
that was sitting up around 85 or the
late 80s and again that's grown in the
last survey to 99 so that's just really
positive and encouraging to see that
continual Improvement in that level of
pride
um when we ask people what makes them
proud to live in South invercargill
these are some of the themes that came
up it's the people that's the
overwhelming response we get is that
sense of neighborliness
um the way people care for one another
um
people also love the community events
and activities the fact that
everything's here on their doorstep
those amenities that are close by to
them in the South invercargill area
and there's this survey also really
helps to drive the priorities for the
years going forward and so we always try
and get some insight into what we could
do to make South invercargill even
better and so these are some of the
things that I were identified by the
community more community events more
activities for young people beautifying
our spaces and improving that that
shopping area tidying that up a bit so
I'm just going to touch on a few of
those things now and some of those
future priorities for us as an
organization
um
so the community events as I said um
that's came through strongly and in that
survey more than a quarter of our
responses referred to community events
as being something that I don't want to
see more of
um and the community events that we run
range from something
um really small like a grasshopper or a
crop top up to where obviously our large
Signature Events like the street party
and World kindness day which grows each
year
um they also cater to a range of
interests in demographics so we've got
quite a few events aimed at young people
like our school holiday activities
um and our parkour which you can see in
the middle there which is growing in
popularity
um and then we have uh things for our
elderly Community we have people
um with a gardening or food interest
with our composting workshops or
gardening workshops we've got people
with creative interests with our
um craft swaps and that kind of thing so
there's something there for everyone
providing a range of different events
and activities for people to engage in
and we're conscious of trying to spread
out across the South invercargill area
too so we do run a lot of events where
we are in our community park but we're
looking to
um spread that out over the South
invercargill area so um
yeah we've often has the trolley Derby
on children's day at Elizabeth Park and
rimu Street and we've got our drive-in
movies which we're hoping to have coming
up in the next couple of months which
will be out further east of um in South
invercargill too so just spreading
across
the South invercargill area
one of the other priorities this comes
through in our engagement is um having
more opportunities for our young people
um and we had the chance with Vodafone
Foundation concentrating some investment
in invercargill to um get some funding
to have a new dangatahi projects
coordinator so we've got um Stacy
mataroa who's just come on board with us
at the start of this year and she's
driving a few trials for
um things we can be doing providing
opportunities for our orangutaki in the
area
um so some of the priority areas for
that are around improving access and
reducing transport barriers and
connecting to employment opportunities
and some tech skill development so we're
looking at
um some podcasting and also some
computer building qualifications and
showcasing the talents we've got some
incredible talent in our community and
just providing a platform we've got a
great stage down there that we don't use
as much as we could so just utilizing
what we've got in our community and the
talents of our people to um yeah bring
that all together
you know
and one of the other
um focuses is around food security and
resilience I think we all understand
that increasing cost of living and
pressures that everyone is facing
um and through covid-19 we sort of
developed our pay it forward
um program which delivers food Parcels
to people that need them
um and so we've already been doing a bit
of work in that food security space and
obviously for a long time since we've
started we've had had our community
gardens and our fruit and nut Orchards
across the South invercargill and parks
and reserves so we've already been doing
a bit of work in that space But we're
just looking to amplify that
um so we're looking at
um continuing some workshops around food
some cooking classes and Catering to
different demographics so we're down at
sit o week recently connecting with the
students so looking to develop some
cooking classes for students
um young men's seniors catering to
different parts of our community
um supporting veggie gardening through
workshops and resources we've connected
in with parakori a local um
person Amelia is working in that space
around reducing waste from a tiamati
perspective
um and continuing our work through our
pay it forward program and continuing
that to support the Mahi of our our
volunteer teams in the fruit and nut and
community garden
space
so those are just some of the key Focus
areas
um moving forward at continuing all of
the existing stuff we do but that's just
highlighting a few of those future Focus
areas
moving on March we noted was neighbors
aotearo a month nationally so south of
Live's theme was uh to reflect that was
about sharing and we just put up sharing
you know the skills the knowledge the
energy and as a poster of the events
scheduled for
um March and that's and that's only some
of the extra things that we're doing
over and above normal uh picnic in the
park is sorry yeah picnic at the pod
has a particular event coming up this
coming Sunday with uh rangatahi youth
lots of uh entertainment and access to
services
at closing uh whakatalki reinforces for
us that it's not the individual but it's
the collective successes which
strengthens out the lives work from the
many who contribute to our vision which
is a Vibrant Community that takes a lead
in its own future you're always welcome
down you can find out more about us on
any of the media sites and happy to
answer any questions
and I do have a few hard copies of those
survey results if anyone is interested
in taking run away with them
thanks Courtney thanks Beryl uh Tom
Yeah question
for me
um I mean I I think says Alive's been an
extraordinary success story it really
has so congratulations for that I mean I
think it's an accident a geography you
know that the South City shopping is in
the south west there's only marginally
south of it's in the south west so my
question is about the extent to which
you've been able to engage with the
south eastern part of the city uh which
is you know
it's fun away from you know unions as
actually promising the in the The Heart
of the City have you managed to engage
with them are you doing much to make
sure that they are engaged the law much
further away through I'll ask let
Courtney had mostly that but we have as
I said when you talk about the hubby you
forget about the all the other things so
our neighborhood support groups our zero
rubbisher Dr streets um all of the the
some of the gardens that are happening
are right across the area and including
down south as far as Clifton working
with groups there
we have uh recently done a Facilities
Review because some of the feedback we
were getting was that transport and
access issue and Courtney having done it
would like to probably add a little bit
more yeah so I've just been seeing what
facilities are available for the
community to use across the whole South
invercargill area looking at churches
Sports and starting to meet the schools
I met with one today and just yeah
seeing what spaces of available
connecting in with those different
groups making them aware of what we're
doing and building those relationships
with them so we do reach across we have
a really good relationship with the
schools in our area too and they're sort
of spread out
um east and south
um so we have a good connection in with
and connect with people through the
schools as well
um and our fruit and that orchards are
spread across
um
across the South invercargill area one
thing that the fruit and nut team have
just initiated in the last month is um
an orchard of the month so they're doing
a mailbox drop and all the houses that
surround the parks where they've got an
orchard
um and invite them to a little to an
evening where they can learn more about
the Orchard and see what's there so
that's another way of just developing
our reach across the whole South
invercargill area and connecting and
building those relationships yeah just a
specific example just to add to that is
um when we did the Facilities Review and
went to different Club groups and that
they said we'd love the locals to be
able to use the facilities in the area
but they at the time they were often and
I'm sorry this sounds very
um I can't think of the word but a lot
of the more older men and they running
those organizations and they were saying
but we don't know about Facebook or how
to connect with social media or things
like that so then that alerted us to how
can we support you to you know learn how
to you know operate Facebook and the
heavier places available for the locals
to better use so sometimes you know and
I guess that's what it means with
community-led development is that the
Community Drive things that become
important me Clark
a couple of things Barrel um just
reinforcing what Tom said about the
success of South life but a couple of
issues you got the new pump track down
in Elizabeth
um do you know any sort of levels of
Engagement there do the very young news
at Park
do you know and why I ask is
when you go into someone like Alexander
that's got a pump track a BMX track a
skate park and the kids learn along
where they run around learn the road
rules are all in the same area but
they're separate the younger kids don't
mix very well with the older kids and I
just wondered like if you look at what's
sitting in otatara moment which is that
young pump track which is highly
successful
would something like that fit in and
around Russell Park Russell square or
would it would it compete against Watson
Elizabeth Park as well
are you saying if we developed a pump
track at Russell's should we develop a
muscle well
the we as the council we not not the
community we
um you know I mean I've I've seen these
issues at owner Tara and the number of
kids that are on that Park but they are
predominantly younger kids that would
not be on a road and wouldn't be on a
BMX track a BMX part of either the
levels too high for them and some kids
won't go where there are older kids
either so it's been really good for us
but I just thought why don't we have one
in South City as well
can't promise that but you know that
just begs a question
the community is trying out I just
wondered I didn't want to compete with
what you've already got developed in the
BMX track which is down in Elizabeth
Park
I'm sorry but I can certainly find out a
little bit more yeah that would be
helpful there would be an opportunity to
trial one if you talk through our active
transport coordinator here at Council I
know that they have access to a portable
one that goes to different locations
yeah we have been connecting on with um
active staff and then their transport
person who's spoken about
um I think a pop-up one going to
Elizabeth Park so we're looking to
coordinate them with him around running
an event sure yeah
second question was around Esports which
is a nice fancy way of talking about
kids on on computers unfortunately
um but that's huge as well and I just
wonder whether there's any capacity in
South City
for not a video arcade but somewhere
where these kids can go and play and
compete against each other online
compete which means they're connecting
with people outside yes for about five
years we've been working with James at
your corpse and running free
um youth gaming events and they have
been hugely popular we've had noise
control called because the kids were
having so much fun and laughing and
playing so
um yeah so yeah that's a good problem
um so we've been yeah I know he does
bigger stuff in town but yeah we've been
working with James for a while around
running those events and they are a
great way of reducing isolation that can
come with gaming and building different
positives of it and getting the kids all
in a room together so guess what I was
thinking was not just the one-off events
that James does because I mean I've had
some interaction with him as well but
more of a a regular pop-up space where
people could go I don't know Friday
nights Saturdays and Sundays but not
compete with school where they they have
a venue that might be open eight nine
ten hours a day because some of these
kids will play that long and they'll
play internationally that long I think
you'll find there's a place in train
that's looking at that yeah well that's
great there is yeah
Grant thank you yeah thanks chair um
yeah firstly congratulations I think the
work you do is outstanding in our
community and so it's really great and
it's good to see you know the numbers
you're bringing back so well done
interested in um
you know two things really obstacles is
there any one or two big obstacles that
need to be removed and if they were
removed you know it would enable your
further success and secondly how does
council you know facilitate your success
more
yeah
um we've been really really we've been
really
really um had a five-year partnership
with the Department until Affairs
they've got a community-led development
program that we've been part of and our
five-year partnership ends in September
this year
um they've got a sixth
due to the feedback from the groups
they've added a sixth transition year
where we get a smaller amount of funding
but that helps us transition to other
fundings but that will mean that yeah
long-term security so what is the
Quantum how much is that
um week it's currently being from them
just over 200 000 a year right
to follow through on that too the um
we've had a sustainability plan in place
because you can't just not react to you
know those sort of things and we don't
want to spend all our time just
constantly fundraising that's I don't
think that's the main purpose no and
um so we've had a sustainability and
play and some of the things we are doing
uh with a view to
um being able to be viable for example
the meeting rooms and perhaps extending
those um looking at some of those
opportunities that we have but that
alone you often find for fundraising
that one of the barriers coming back to
your point is that often people are
really Keen about projects and less Keen
about operations and maintenance and so
that's really important to the community
have told us consistently that they um
they want some key stuff we actually
have the equivalent of two full-time
staff to actually enable them and
coordinate them to do so that's one of
the challenges for that okay just a
secondary in terms of so with the 200
000 so
that would sustain the programs you're
doing now or does that facilitate
additional growth in what you're doing
and allow you to sort of Reach Out
further to you toward and other aspects
will develop safe you know around your
um your youth unemployment the 200 000
is what we're currently getting from
each year from that Dia funding but
we're still a supplementing that with
other funding like from Vodafone
Foundation or
um MSD for food security initiatives so
some of those other discrete projects
get their own Super funding as well yeah
yeah so yeah we might manage five
different funders
if you were to fund what's the time
frame so you just wouldn't want it every
12 months you'd was it is it three years
is it five years
yeah what's the optimum time to be able
to say we can dig into this and you know
invest really three to five years three
to five years yeah that's been one of
the benefits of having this five-year
partnership is that certainty
five years probably
Trish
I know the wonderful work you do and I
really really love it Courtney is there
any chance of extending or getting
another lot from DIA another five years
no I think that um that not through that
um crd program because they're always
bringing on new groups around the
country there's about 18 Partnerships
that they currently have and they keep
that number around 18 to 20 so as groups
finish their five years somebody else a
few groups come on so there's
opportunities for other funding from the
DIA like lotteries and cogs but not in
that crd program at this stage yeah
I do agree that there could be value
because there's quite a number of those
Partnerships that just stop and I don't
think that's the purpose for about the
life our purpose is to continue and be
viable
and you can see that
that everything you can get on is doing
your work you don't have to worry about
your operational stuff and although I've
alluded to it the the volunteer hours if
you put a dollar value to that and yet
the the volunteer hours alone show the
support that South invercargill
Community are putting in behind us you
know it's all driven by them it's the
only time I've been in a governance role
that's completely 180 reversed and we're
there to enable the community to succeed
Evelyn oh Kia Ora as you know I'm a
neighbor I'm a user
um
one of the things that concerned me when
I was there not long ago is it would
appear that supply chain issues are
affecting the viability of the pantry
um I don't know if that's an unfair
comment but it just seemed like
we're still in this post-covert
uncertainty things you used to have eggs
eggs are challenging at the moment how
does that affect
your viability because the return from
the pantry is supposed to help with the
whole level of activity is that an issue
for you at the moment or
not as much of an issue as I might think
as an outsider to be fair I'd say it was
an issue it's a social Enterprise that
was established with the purpose of
providing the funds as part of that
sustainability plan with a variety of
reasons it hasn't been you know as as
successful as we've hoped and we're in
the middle of reviewing refreshing and
making some changes there
um to as I also indicated in the um
PowerPoint
it's inadvertently become the community
have the place together and that wasn't
actually strangely enough the original
purpose so I think we have to reflect
that and make changes in different ways
thank you
thank you and thank you for your Mahi I
had the pleasure of sitting with several
of the south of light volunteers at the
midwinter fundraising dinner and the
value that they have get
from being able to be a part of what it
is that south of the life delivers is
um substantial you know their pride was
genuine and heartwarming
so thank you for your presentation and
for taking the time to come along
thank you
Council as our next item is the minutes
of the community wellbeing committee
back on February 14th
if somebody wants to move that they are
confirmed councilor cracker Council
Dermody can put that all in favor
against
carried the extraordinary meeting on
it's no sorry that's
extraordinary Community well-being fund
it's what's so useful having these two
similarly named committees which I
promise we will change soon
very good thank you
put that all in favor
aye against carried
tab six is the minutes of the district
licensing committee now here's an
interesting thing and that we've never
received these before now what they are
is a record of the work that I do each
week and signing off manager
certificates renewals
um
license premises renewals new licenses
special events and the like
I'm ringing in my ears as the comment
that Tom makes recording during the
workshop about unnecessary paperwork so
I'm this is something new that you
haven't had before is it interesting for
you to see the statistics I have
actually held back the names of the
managers but their application numbers
are in there just for for privacy
reasons but is it is it useful yeah yeah
yes I think so cool okay one of the
interest there are a few changes
um that the
DLC might bring in this year which is
part of what's being looked at
Nationwide and for your interest we also
have a hearing next Wednesday
like to move that the report is received
Evelyn put that all in favor
aye against Kerry
the active communities fund
it's really just an update this was
something that we administered within
Council we have transferred
Administration to it to active Southland
um
on the new Council representative on
that and they are getting together
later this month or early next month to
set out the new terms and conditions so
it's really just informative
something like to move the reports
receive tuition Leslie questions
Tom
uh chair the the only question I have
it's not actually covered in the report
is
um by what process does council approve
the bulk funding of this I think it was
I mean it was obviously before I was on
Council but there was a decision to move
the funding to our body it knew
something about what would actually
approve it's a good idea
um but presumably Council approved the
amount each year do they get uh there is
an allocation that comes each year from
sport New Zealand I think it used to be
the Hillary commission but it was by
Council resolution that it shifted
oh so it's not actually rate funded as
no no okay that was my question it's
like creative communities that the money
comes from an external it was the old
Hillary commission funding when the
Hillary commission ceased to exist so
councils throughout New Zealand were
given
money from the old Hillary commission
most councils when we explored it had
actually used their funding
um we we
operated slightly differently and that
we saw it as a long-term funding for our
active communities but we also saw it
um at the time we made the decision as
time for a body with more deep
than the active community space was able
to administer the fund we checked with
the what is now Sports New Zealand who
replaced the Hillary commission to
ensure in the spirit of the original
funding that that was an appropriate
decision on our behalf they supported us
doing that we felt the time had come for
that much wider view of at the community
funding and use in
air
active Southland was the obvious body to
take that but no it wasn't rates funding
do we still act as a post box for the
money do we get the money then pass it
to you know so it goes directly straight
to active South and now Alex quick
declaration
declaration I obviously set on as a
trustee on the rst active Southland so
um like Council cycle is quite like
quite rightly said we ended up having a
wealth of Reserve there that ended up
compounding and we weren't actually
getting it out to the community as
quickly as it was compounding year on
year and they also sorry actor South
would also administer several other
funds on behalf of like sport New
Zealand like the Tomato fund and that so
what we were finding is that people
would come to us and active South and
had a lot more knowledge on where to go
and what could be funded through watch
funds so like Council cyber said we made
the decision to pass it over
because I guess the single source of
Truth rather than trying to push people
around
it was one of those decisions that just
made really good sense yeah funnier I
noticed that the um applications primary
benefit the invercargill city area is it
is
purely yeah
do we have a mover and secondary for
receiving the report Nigel and Evelyn
questions
thanks for the question Tom what that
then all in favor
aye against
Carrie which brings us to the activities
report
joining me at the top of the table for
her last meeting with Council before
deserting us to go to Timur
thank you Mr chair so uh I will draw
your attention to a couple of things
that have come up in the past month one
is an increase in parking disputes a
massive increase that we've seen and as
a result of that staff believed the
systemic issue is a lack of Engagement
with the public and so they're putting
together a campaign to be able to help
regular users of our city street parking
with how to use the different technology
and making sure the equipment is working
all of the time
you'll also notice that
um we've anything any questions you've
got about the media we've got Lisa here
to comment on that today and notice that
our Leisure and Recreation teams have
put together a really thorough overview
of what's been going on in their spaces
so we welcome any questions
so again following on from the question
that Tom raised this morning do you find
the information in the activities report
sufficient
um do you want more do you have actually
any questions about what's what's
contained in in this report Evelyn good
morning
um I'm not sure why I have not noticed
this before or perhaps it hasn't been so
noticeable before but there's actually a
month time leg in this so we're in March
we haven't got a report that covers
February I don't mean to be particularly
picky about it I just wonder if the leg
means that we're not quite as surprised
as we could be so I can explain that
reports come through a process
operationally and they need to be with
uh the executive leadership team two
weeks before so the data we never quite
meet the cut off so it's been agreed
previously that yes there'll always be a
bit of a lag we'll try to make it as
current as possible
thank you for that clarification
bringing oh thanks chair look just
regarding animal control and um with
with dogs and various lists it has here
and under infringements what what would
barking dogs uh be classified you know
like as an uh complaint to council about
ongoing barking dogs and that's that
work in progress or
um I've just the reason I'm asking this
I know two houses very close to me have
Lodge complaints and um they're just
taking a while and I just wondered you
know whether this gets registered on the
list or
yeah through you Mr cheers so it would
be lodged as an rfes a request for
service and they remain open until
they're resolved with barking dogs there
is a detailed process that our staff go
through which relates to our enforcement
strategy and policy the first piece is
education there's also monitoring that
takes place both by monitoring by the
people who have complained about the
dogs and by our staff completing work
and then finally for example we had one
last year where we actually the outstand
the result was the dog needed to be
re-homed as it wasn't able to be
contained from barking they do take some
time you can imagine it can be an
emotional issue for the complainant and
the people who own the dog and staff
work very closely together to resolve
those as fast but also as practical as
possible oh yeah delicate subject so can
I is it like a six month working program
we don't have a time frame around it uh
as such but it and I can't speak to
individual issues but happy to discuss
further offline or to get the actual
staff engaged with that so yeah so
getting back to my original thing it's
not really listed here as uh it's not
broken down to that detail so you've got
it's a request for services it's a
requests wandering dogs
right okay so there could be there could
be multiple things like sheep out on a
road or goat escaped right we have
multiple types so in terms of the
information that's where it's really
valuable for staff to understand what
level of detail you want and how you
want to receive it and whether you want
it monthly or whether you'd like it
quarterly or something like that
so to follow on top
yeah so I've got a line of people oh
sorry no I'll add you to it so I've got
Leslie rear Grant then Tom so Leslie
thanks Mr chair um you asked about the
usefulness of the information and I just
wanted to say if anything I'm quite
happy with the activities report to see
more not less simply because we can't be
at every activity or event or public
program and it is really worthwhile to
see the report of what is happening not
that we want to be involved in the
operational matters but simply to help
keep councilors abreast of exactly what
is happening in the community what we
are delivering seeing some of the photos
is great I think I think actually the
activities reports have improved with
some photos being added to them over the
time I've been on Council and just
hearing what the teams are doing and
delivering I think is helping to build
that wider picture for all of us as
counselors of what is being delivered so
from the point of view of asking for the
usefulness I actually think the activity
reports are very useful and
from my perspective could even be a
little bit more descriptive than they
are of particular events thanks for the
feedback listening I um concur with
cancer sober I just wanted to on under
the compliance table the last entry
abandoned vehicles
and January 2022 we had 19 identified as
a bandit and in 2023 it says not used
could you what what does it
through you Mr chair I can help you
understand that so the compliance team
did some analysis on what we were
classing as an abandoned vehicle whereas
what was actually classed as a parking
complaint and so for example you could
be living at Street 1A or outside your
street you go out there's a vehicle
that's always parked there it's never
moved you ring up and it's actually a
parking complaint because we don't know
it's an abandoned vehicle it might just
be that it's moved when you're not not
aware so we're reclassifying them to be
more aligned with the legislation and so
it becomes a parking complaint as
opposed to abandoned vehicle before it
gets to that stage that gives us more
opportunity to infringe or to take
compliance measures with that approach
thank you thank you grant yeah just um
similar to Leslie's comment around the
reporting I think is very useful but
referencing this morning's conversation
would it be useful in the purpose to
define the instances we're reporting
back against air legislative
requirements around service or something
like that so
um it's framed in the report that we're
you know it's an update on facility um
activities particularly related to your
obligation to
deliver this service to our community so
it gives context to the report and
that'll help Drive what's in the report
to ensure we've got the oversight that
we're meeting the requirements of your
obligations does that make sense can I
clarify do you mean against what we're
reporting on on the ltp or our
legislative requirements well probably
both yeah our obligations be it under
the legislative or air commitment to ltp
which is you know it's put together with
their Community I just think it'd help
sort of tighten it up and give us
confidence that we're delivering those
services or Effectiveness around it
thank you uh Tom then Evelyn
so I mean I'm just gonna
getting all the information so I
hesitate but
um I mean you often find that these
sorts of reports are come organically
you know a counselor in 1859 you know
asked for a particular piece of
information so it started to appear in
the report and it just keeps appearing
forever and so each time a counselor
asks for a new piece of information it
just adds to the burden of collecting it
and and you know of course all the
information in here is interesting but
well what I'd I would like to hear from
Council staff is whether particular
pieces of information that just take
disproportionate amount of time to
prepare and whether you know not being
the case whether we actually need to see
that and and it's not only this report I
mean I think it's more broadly all
reports and I think it's something that
now Michael's note here but I mean I I
think it's something that the chief
executive should be looking at with
these staffers
um you know as a lot of stuff which
costs a centuries and everything
centuries but as as a stuff that's
disproportionately time consuming where
you know and ask us the question do you
really need to see this Council because
it takes us you know two hours a week to
prepare it and it's you know so that was
really the yeah
except in the point that counselor soap
is making which is an interesting read
for sure it is a fair point Tom I guess
I was asked the question as chair at the
beginning of the term what I wanted to
see in there and I thought it was better
actually for the committee to come to
terms with what it was it was
looking at first before before asking
you that question and we're at that
stage now but
Trudy do you want to respond from a
staff perspective and the time that it
takes for
compiling that report
certainly so there are we are improving
our reporting all of the time and we've
got a rhythm with what we have to report
on it so we need to keep our eye on the
data we need to be making sure that
we're resolving things within different
time frames for legislative requirements
so from a terms of onus the the
challenges getting staff to start to
analyze what they're seeing for you and
put that into context and I think it's a
good habit for staff it's not onerous if
you develop the Rhythm and I know
Jonathan to be able to speak to that
potentially 18 months ago there wasn't a
rhythm there's a rhythm now
um and I know that for our Leisure and
Recreation services there's a sense of
Pride being able to bring this to the
table as well but I know that Michael
was always looking to make sure we have
the most effective and efficient use of
our staff and he will that's something I
know he will want to take up with the
executive leadership team to make sure
that that is happening in an appropriate
manner thank you it was for a while that
we got down simply to reporting on the
numbers that we were required to provide
as reporting on the kpis and what we
were missing with those nuggets those
great little stories that actually
formed part of the activities report
which was something that we didn't
necessarily have any jurisdiction over
as Governors but gave us a sense of
Pride to receive and certainly gave the
staff a sense of Pride to be able to
share with us and I think they've formed
an important part of of what we received
Jonathan was there anything that that
you wanted to add
I think the parts are being covered
um what I will say is that I myself have
found myself sometimes grasping around
the commentary and so what I chose to do
this time rain was not include a
commentary and I think there's something
to be said for going back to the council
offices and just maybe giving them that
license
thank you Trish
the good work that's going on the
Facebook
um thank you it seems to be some a good
stories coming out all the time and so
it makes me feel good so thank you
yeah
um just one thing that isn't reported
against this time
um and I'm not sure if I'm missing but
in terms of compliance non-consented or
non-conforming
activities
um how
much of that is there and how long does
it take to resolve
those sorts of things because I don't
see it reported against this time but
I'm sure there are some Jonathan
who are three
um
if they are similar to animal control
and barking complaints that they'd come
through as RFS
um and it is very open-ended in some
cases to how long they can take to
resolve we work to resolve them as
practically as we can but by all means
we can certainly include the
non-compliance RFS we may need to divide
them into the various categories
building Etc planning
I think you I was asked by somebody to
ask the questions so
but they also say under the property
records team that the table there that
shows last year's comparison to this
year's so I'm aware that there's been a
lot of significant work put in by your
team to have enable the public to access
these records what would because you're
leaving us
um what would you say
um
under the property records
information we've got has been a real
huge significant
um matter in terms of dealing and
delivering on those Services as they
stole things at your
concerned about
I think it's more things I think there's
an opportunity for so it's deciding as a
council on a path forward for online
access to files and where that sits and
what that may look like and uh what what
is possible that if I look reflect a
year ago we had a very new team and for
them to be delivering as a real credit
tool of those staff and they continue to
deliver they do a lot of work that goes
unnoticed and unseen but we've seen a
decline in the property Market we can
see it cooling off because of the drop
in the number of
um property file requests but I think
it's more about opportunities what we as
the digitization process continues where
does council want to be in terms of
self-service and what will be
appropriate level of access if there's a
public viewing process
yeah just a couple things for me um
yeah I think it's too much in the report
we talked about this one Tom's alluded
to that as well it's nice to know
um but we don't need to know it's
operational I mean when I think about
the areas that I would like to know
about my animal control is clearly one
it's been a niche for us in the past and
certainly the whole consenting Services
area is an area that if we don't get
regular feedback and that we can't
answer criticism we get from the
community
I don't particularly need to know
whether the cafe of this space Palace is
doing okay or not and I am mindful of
the number of vacancies we hold and the
constant feedback we get from the group
managers at they're under pressure to
provide a lot of information to us so I
just wonder whether um you know for my
animal controls and and conceding could
be a monthly reporters committee but the
others could be quarterly or even six
monthly in some cases just so we have an
overview but we just don't need that
constant feedback now I know one of the
beauties of constantly collecting for
report is that it keeps people focused
but we should find other mechanisms to
do it than than extra work I think
thank you
Council has any other questions comments
or feedback
I like the report
thanks Mania
and thanks for your engagement with that
as well um like I said I wanted to leave
it a couple of meetings before asking
and I also see it as one of those things
that
um is is living and that if our
requirements change through the term and
what it is that we want to see
um that we can make those adjustments as
we go so again that continuous feedback
would be useful
there are no further questions would
somebody like to move that we received
sorry I'm sorry I'd remiss not to
mention that these sort of monthly
reports could include Topics by
exception so if something was blowing
out in a particular you know that the
staff felt we should have a bit of a
heads up on that would be okay too
I think that reporting by exception is
always useful
Bond
I'll put that all in favor against Kerry
and there being no further items in our
public agenda before
moving into public excluded for the
reasons as outlined in the agenda I will
take this opportunity and open meeting
to wish truly well
uh thank you very much for your service
over your time here after we stole you
from Southland District
um we wish you well uh returning to
Timaru home of the foreign inferior
cheese roll
a total that they quite unjustly tried
to steal from us a couple of years ago
but there was an incident where our
former made to try and poison John
Campbell and proving that ours was
better I don't think he was the right
representative
um it's a lovely space we look forward
to hearing back from you but thank you
for the changes that you've made during
your time here and for the
professionalism from which you've
carried out your job
I'll move that we go into public
excluded for confirming uh we're
confirming one set of minutes and
receiving the others for the reason it's
outlined second by councilman Germany
put that all in favor against carried
thank you very much to those who have
joined us on the live stream